uh our first speaker this morning is
mary graybar
mary is making her first appearance at a
hillsdale college event and
we hope there will be many more she was
born in the former yugoslavia
in what is today slovenia she was
brought to america when she was two
years old by her parents who escaped the
then communist regime
early in her career she worked in
advertising and as a freelance
writer and she later earned a phd in
english from the university of georgia
she's held a number of teaching
positions including most recently
in the program in american democracy and
citizenship
at emory university she has also written
many articles about the corruption
of education i guess that's a constantly
a good source lots of material there
she founded the non-profit dissident
prof education
project which only came about after what
she calls
quote a two-year struggle with the obama
irs
i don't need to remind all of you that
she's not the only conservative who
struggled with the irs
during the obama administration she's
currently a resident fellow at the
alexander hamilton institute
for the study of western civilization
where she is working on a biography of
the black conservative
writer george schuyler
thank you her most recent book was
published in 2019 and is titled
debunking howard zinn exposing the fake
history that turned a generation
against america i wonder how many of
today's protesters learned their
american history
from howard zinn she'll be drawing on
themes
from her book for her talk this morning
would you please welcome to the podium
mary graybar
well thank you for that nice
introduction
i'm going to try to sum up a lot of the
things that
are in my book today
and i was supposed to talk about the
influence of howard zinn today
howard zinn represents the classic
chicken and egg
dilemma people often ask
which came first howard's inn or the far
left were drift of education
how is it that a book like a people's
history of the united states was allowed
to get into the classroom in the first
place
to any reader with a modicum of
knowledge about history
zinn's book first published in 1980
and continuously published ever since is
a
deeply biased and flawed anti-american
polemic zen book presents a view of the
united states is irredeemably corrupt
with a discoverer christopher columbus
committing genocide the founders setting
up a government to enrich
the rich and powerful and capitalists
getting rich off slaves and workers
the bill of rights voting petitioning
initiative and hard work mean nothing in
this corrupt regime
consider zinn's take on the founding
which he describes in his chapter four
titled tyranny is tyranny
around 1776 certain important people in
the english colonies made a discovery
that would prove enormously useful for
the next 200 years
they found that by creating a nation a
symbol
a legal unity called the united states
they could take over
land profits and political power from
favorites
of the british empire in the process
they could hold back a number of
potential rebellions
and create a consensus of popular
support for the rule
of a new privileged leadership
end of quote the myth of the revolution
as he calls it
was that it was on behalf of a united
people
why was this a myth because quote
some americans were clearly omitted from
the circle of united interests drawn by
the declaration of independence
indians black slaves women
aside from these exclusions zinn
presents what is
in his opinion a greater flaw he points
out
quote the declaration talked about
government and political rights
but ignored the existing inequalities in
property
and then he asks suggestively and how
could people truly have
equal rights with stark differences in
wealth
the corrupt founding carries over
throughout american history
into the 20th century to world war ii
which zinn describes as quote a war
waged by a government whose chief
beneficiary was a wealthy elite
the alliance between big business and
government
well back to the very first proposals of
alexander hamilton
end of quotation in zinn's view
we did not defeat fascism
rather fascism's quote essential
elements militarism racism
imperialism were absorbed
into the already poisoned bones
of the victors end of quotation
when i began writing my book debunking
howard's inn
i thought i would be exposing the biases
but although i had been witnessing and
writing about the corruption
in education for years and though i had
graded many shoddy student papers
sometimes plagiarized i was shocked
by how much zinn had gotten away with
zinn presented leading questions often
several in a row
he falsified evidence he left out
key words when quoting sources to give
the opposite impression
of what they meant he plagiarized
and not from a book of history but from
a book for high school students by a
fellow marxist radical
who was a screenwriter and a novelist
this was on columbus on which much of
zinn's claim to fame
as a path-breaking historian is based
he also used as sources works of fiction
statements by anonymous people
and a holocaust denying historian
he presented he valorized the black
panthers
and treated the naacp dismissively
he presented american indians as woke
denizens of 1960s communes
he said all women in colonial america
were slaves and he used the word slaves
my book documents how zinn deliberately
deceived
the big question remains how did zen
get away with this for 40 years
which brings us back to the chicken and
egg question
howard zinn i maintain was the chicken
a communist chicken born in 1922
to russian jewish immigrant parents he
was
early on influenced by the communist
proselytizers
coming into his brooklyn neighborhood
during his teen years
according to the best interpretation of
zinn's
fbi file we can be confident the zinn
was a member of the communist party usa
from about 1948 to 1953.
this was while zinn was attending
graduate school on the gi bill
after serving in world war ii as a
bombardier
he earned his phd from colombia and
began teaching at spelman college in
1956.
following party directives howard zinn
led the long march of marxists into the
institutions
thus laying the egg that hatched the new
left at spelman
and later at boston university zinn
a charismatic pied piper radicalized
students
turning them against the college
administrations that sought to maintain
academic standards zinn also
churned students against their own
country he was an
influential mentor to the violent
student nonviolent
coordinating committee boasting of such
leaders as stokely carmichael and h wrap
brown
at boston universities and inspired
students to resist the draft for the
vietnam war
and to view ho chi minh as the true
jeffersonian democrat
it was one of his boston university
students from the 1970s
who became wealthy in our capitalist
system
that zinn disparages and who in 2007
donated the money to start the
non-profit zen
education project
zinn was given the opportunity to put
his communist
version of american history into a book
published by harper collins
as i discovered it follows the contours
of a history book written by cpusa
chairman william z foster in 1951
the year party member howard zinn was
teaching marxism at the brooklyn
cpusa headquarters as his fbi file
reveals
by 1980 a change had come
over the profession at the 1969 meeting
of the american historical association
the radicals began to take over
harvard historian oscar handland rude
the changes
in his 1971 essay living history
he described quote the pressures toward
falsification that were arising from the
radical historians
objectives of social activism
he compared these pressures to what
happened in the soviet union
when scholarship was put in service of
ideology
handlin wrote it was one of stalin's
most
impressive achievements to have
converted marxism
to an instrument of state purpose and it
was not
by coincidence that history was the
first discipline to suffer in the
process
the soviet union did more than impose
an official party line on
interpretations of trotsky's role in the
revolution of 1917.
it actually expunged the name trotsky
from the record
so that the fact of the commissar's
existence disappeared
what started in the domain of history
led in time to lysinko's invasion of the
natural sciences
end of quote i think the analogy applies
to our current situation
zin smeared such great historians as
samuel
elliott morrison and bernard baylin with
false charges of defending genocide and
tyranny
and he did it with such moral fervor
as he pretended to uncover historical
secrets
so as to disabuse any sophomore of a
desire to read these historians
or anyone other than howard zinn
champion of the oppressed indeed
zinn's book to many a naive adolescent
has the power of revelation as others
have noted
today we are suffering from our own
lysenko-ism
the sciences including medicine are
suffering from quotas
as well as their overall rejection of
euro-centric
thinking down to the idea of rejecting
two plus two equals four
in the wake of the summer's rioting and
struggle
sessions librarians have also
vowed to decolonize their libraries
one book these librarians would keep is
zinn's the people's history of the
united states
so will amazon and other retailers
considering how well it continues to
sell
the book has broken records in terms of
sales for its
type topping 3 million
today the book is sold in adaptations
such as a young
people's history of the united states
used now for several years in all 8th
grade classrooms
in portland oregon and surrounding areas
no surprise about what's going on in
portland
there are spin-off people's histories
of everything from the civil war to art
history to sports
as well as graphic adaptations and films
nearly a hundred and twenty thousand
educators have signed up to receive
material from the zen education project
and over 300 000 follow it on social
media
as i can attest after participating in
the recent white house conference on
american history
they are ready to spring into action
whenever
their hero is criticized
whereas at one time teachers would
photocopy pages of zinn's book
to distribute and then collect before
the end of class
as i learned from attending teachers
conferences
since the revision of the ap advanced
placement u.s history standards
under the obama administration the book
or
chapters of a people's history are
frequently and openly assigned
to high school students other history
courses tend to follow the lead of ap
even other subjects like high school
english
follow zinn's example and present ho chi
minh
speech his proclamation of independence
during his propaganda stunt
in 1945 as a legitimate work of
rhetoric to be investigated alongside
the declaration of independence
for its appeals to ethos pathos and
logos
many of zinn's claims such as the sins
of omission of slaves women and
indians in the founding have become
commonplace
in textbooks since zinn's book came out
most textbooks now begin with
christopher columbus and also portray
him as a genocidal rapist to zindas
zinn was proud of how his book had
changed americans views of columbus
and in my book i chronicled how columbus
statues were being defaced on columbus
day
and how municipalities and states were
replacing columbus day with indigenous
people's day
then recently cbs
a few days ago reported that at least 33
statues of columbus
have been taken down or are in the
process of being removed since the
renewed
black lives matter protests began in
late spring
they were either toppled by protesters
voted to be removed or stored away to
avoid vandalism
what is the reason christopher columbus
committed genocide
as the protesters claim as we know
protesters had moved on from confederate
statues and from columbus
and on to any figure in american history
in a summer of writing
the zen education project attacks exempt
501c3
distributes lessons based on zinn's book
and also material for teachers
to engage their students in political
lobbying
they offer abolished columbus day
packets that include sample resolutions
resources and articles to teachers
the project's lessons are also
overtly political frequently naming
republicans
and president trump and indicting him as
a re
racist xenophobe the zen education
project and other zen acolytes repeat
zinn's own claims
and argue that he was a path breaker in
writing a history from the bottom
up the perspective left out of
traditional histories
of the common people african-americans
indians workers immigrants
zinn however in a stalinist manner
wiped out such things as the reality of
brutal tribal warfare on the north
american continent
long before europeans arrived the role
of peaceful christians in the
abolitionists and civil rights movements
and the stories of millions of
immigrants like myself
coming to america for a better life and
achieving it
and becoming citizens and celebrating
national holidays like independence day
but for zinn 1776
did not mark the birth of a united
states
remember those excluded and then
in the post-revolutionary society
as he writes the problem of democracy
went far
deeper than constitutional limits on
voting
it lay in the division of society into
rich and poor
for some people had great wealth and
great influence
if they had the land the money the
newspapers the church the educational
system
how could voting however broad cut into
such power
one of his favorite questions zin admits
that madison's argument for an extensive
republic and federalist ten
can be seen as a sensible argument for
having a government which can maintain
peace and avoid continuous
disorder then comes a series of his
questions
but is it the aim of government simply
to maintain
order as a referee between two actual
actually matched
fighters or is it that government has
some special interest in maintaining a
certain kind of order
a certain distribution of what power and
wealth
in that case the disorder they might
worry about is the disorder of popular
rebellion
against those monopolizing the society's
wealth
this interpretation makes sense when one
looks at the economic interests the
social backgrounds of the makers of the
constitution end of quotation
of course the idea that governments
represent
dominant economic interests comes from
charles beard
whose theory which was first put out in
1913
has been repeatedly debunked but which
zinn presents as a long hidden radical
idea that he
is finally revealing for those who would
see
opportunity here in america zinn says
the constitution quote illustrates the
complexity of the american system
that it serves the interests of a
wealthy elite but
also does enough for small property
owners
for middle-income mechanics and farmers
to build a broad base of support
the slightly prosperous people who make
up the space
are buffers against the blacks the
indians the very poor whites
they enable the elite to keep control
with a minimum of coercion
a maximum of law all made palatable
by the fanfare of patriotism
and unity so according to zen
our fundamental rights are hollow shams
in fact according to zen the united
states
has no right to exist zinn writes
that the idea quote that there really
is such a thing as the united states
a community of people with common
interests
a nation is nothing but a pretense
so i ask is it any wonder that
young people some serving in congress
are fighting the very idea of borders
much less enforcement of immigration law
with such ludicrous claims
it's easy to see why most historians
shunned howard zinn's book when it came
out
except for again oscar handlin
who in his review in american scholar
attacked a handful of important points
of fact
noted zinn's presentation of fiction as
fact
and deemed it a quote fairy tale
however zinn's book was then
in 1997 prominently featured
in the oscar-winning movie good will
hunting
and sales shot up the book got more of a
boost after the formation of the zen
education
project in 2007 their lessons
today teach zinn's lessons
that the black panthers were civil
rights activists
that japanese internment camps were
prison camps much like nazi
concentration camps
that vietnam achieved independence
after the withdrawal of you american
troops
that many of the statues of historical
figures
gracing our public places are those of
racists
and that michael brown and other black
men were ruthlessly gunned down by white
police officers
the organizers of black lives matter
were honored with an
award in zinn's name in 2015
and the zen education project has been a
distributor of black lives matter
lessons
and a promoter of black lives matter
week
in schools every february
recently their curriculum writer
ursula wolf raka wrote that the black
lives matter
protests in her city portland oregon
sparked by the quote murder of george
floyd
were as she described it
exhilaratingly extended period
of nationwide protest
wolf raqqa promotes zinn's idea that the
united states is systemically racist
zinn's storyline in his book
is one of the people rising only to be
put down by
the system a word he uses
nearly 200 times the heroes
are the martyrs like abolitionist john
brown
who died violent deaths for their cause
in a people's history zinn makes
outrageous
unhistorical claims such as one on page
23 where he writes there is not a
country
in world history in which racism has
been more important
for so long a time as the united states
this comes after he quotes a lengthy
creatively rendered description of the
arrival of the africans
at jamestown in 1619.
american slavery zinn says was
quote the most cruel form of slavery in
history
this is because of the quote frenzy for
limitless profit that comes from
capitalist
agriculture and because of quote racial
hatred
this racism comes from money incentive
for exploitation
so we've seen how howard zinn presents
1776 as a sham
so which year better represents the
slaveocracy
that pretends to be the united states
you you guessed it it's 1619.
the 1619 project the 100 page new york
times magazine supplement
has been adopted in over 500
schools the zen education
project quite naturally promotes
the 1619 project and offers their own
lessons to supplement it as
in nicole hannah jones's 1619
project narrative in zinn's narrative
the united states has never
gotten over its slave past
zinn calls the civil rights movement of
the 1950s and 1960s the black revolt
he's it emanated he says from the memory
of slavery and after that of segregation
lynching humiliation
and it was not just a memory but a
living presence he says
part of the daily lives of blacks and
generation
after generation what follows then is
langston hughes's poem about the dream
deferred
exploding and a number of similar
passages
from other poems
martin luther king's i have a dream
speech
in 1963 according to zinn
was quote magnificent oratory
but it did not express the anger that
many blacks felt
malcolm x was probably closer to the
mood
of the black community says zinn
ignoring surveys that consistently said
otherwise
zinn writes that the new civil rights
laws did not
change the root condition of black
people
the civil rights bills emphasized voting
but voting was not a fundamental
solution to racism or poverty
racism in zinn's book is also evidenced
in police brutality
zinn presents five dubious cases of
black men
shot or beaten by police zinn claims
these were quote
normal cases and says they were
and i'm quoting endlessly repeated in
the history of the country
coming randomly but persistently
out of a racism deep in the institutions
the mind of the country
it's an example of some of his rhetoric
howard zinn died in 2010
but since then his influence has grown
he was mourned by rock bands and
hollywood celebrities like jane fonda
his words are read in performances
book fairs are held in his name lectures
in his name
are given every year at boston
university barack obama was reported to
have a special
interest in zinn's book in 2011
during the occupy wall street protests
zinn's book was a favorite in the
library of the new york city encampment
out of occupy wall street grew the
american version of antifa
in 2012 as i can personally attest
georgia state university held an all-day
teach-in
for teachers led by the zen education
project it was an effort to stop
legislation that would
forbid the classroom use of la raza
materials
zinn's book has influenced political
leaders
for oklahoma city council member jo beth
hammond a people's history has replaced
the bible
in april 2019 she took her oath of
office on it
instead of the bible last december
a fairfax county virginia school board
member
also took her oath on zinn's book
in maine in 2019
newly elected district attorney natasha
irving
pledged to follow zinn's example from
his autobiography
we also of course have professors now
espousing
the violence of antifa one of them is
mark bray teaching at rutgers probably
today
this is the kind of violence that zinn
glorifies
in his book zinn's book has also
influenced terrorists tarak mahana who
was ultimately found guilty of terrorist
conspiracy with
al qaeda requested a people's history
along with other
reading materials like the autobiography
of malcolm x
and an islamic text according to an
article
published in 2010 boston bomber
zokar and sarnov if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
said that reading a people's history of
the united states
had opened his eyes to america's evil
he had bonded with his history teacher
larry
r aronson a long time friend of the late
howard zinn
willem vance bronson a member of antifa
and the john brown gun club who tried to
blow up an ice detention facility in
2019
left behind a manifesto saying
read howard zinn a people's history of
the united states
he said it would reveal the quote
fascism ascendant
in the u.s a new book in defense of
looting
uses zinn as one of many marxist sources
this year many schools are following
the lead of the zen education project
and teaching black lives matter
curriculum
zen education project has been reminding
teachers of black lives matter week
every february encouraging them to wear
t-shirts
advertising such and to use their
lessons such as
when black lives matter why
teach reconstruction by adam sanchez
this lesson begins every day seems to
bring new horrors
as the u.s president's racist rhetoric
and policies
have provided an increasingly
encouraging environment
for attacks on black people and other
communities of
color in the buffalo new york
public school districts blm lessons will
begin with pre-k
and will infuse black lives matter
guiding principles
into everyday curriculum and resources
there is a service that adapts news
articles for grade appropriate reading
levels called new zealand
as one of its partners it has the zen
education
project to put the spin on the news
a year ago two teacher teach-ins
really continuing education programs
on abolishing columbus day were put on
by the zen education
project one was held at the smithsonian
as i reported in my book the zen
education
project for a fee provides trainers
to schools across the country
taxpayers through the national endowment
for the humanities
subsidize continue summer continuing
education
programs for teachers coordinated by
or with the zen education project
one being held this coming summer
at duke university called the civil
rights movement
grassroots perspectives features
veterans from the student non-violent
coordinating committee
the group mentored by zinn in the 1960s
writing the curriculum are deborah
menkar
co-director of the zen education project
and ursula wolf raqa one of
the organization's two curriculum
directors the one who had praised the
black lives matter protests in portland
she too wolf rocca
regularly infuses her articles and
lessons with anti-trump invective
one article published in september 2018
bore the headline civics will not
save us from trump
this is not the first time such a
workshop was put on
in 2018 a similar one was conducted
again at duke with the zen education
project's mencart as the curriculum
coordinator
the zen education project i think
was disappointed that their lessons
offered for this
constitution day in a mailing labeled
black lives matter rethinking
constitution day in 2020
and beginning with these words black
lives did not matter to the rich white
men who met in
1787 were challenged by the president
of the united states and me
i was so happy to get that invitation
mere hours after my talk at the white
house conference
on american history on constitution day
the zen education project sent
out a fundraising email stating
teaching people's history is about
empowering
and invigorating students to better
understand the perspectives of workers
women black
indigenous and people of color whose
voices are too
often erased in the corporate produced
textbooks
but mary graybar doesn't want young
people to hear those voices
graybar who has written an anti-howard
zinn
book and travels the country attacking
zinn and the zen education project
said at the white house conference on
american history
that zinn's writing imposes the false
idea that the united states is
characterized by quote
systemic racism wealth inequality and
police brutality
end of my quote graybar offered no
evidence
to refute this critique of u.s history
of course they knew about my book and
the evidence i provide there
they seemed to know my travel schedule
but they did not even mention the title
of my book
instead they charged that i quote
fretted that impressionable readers have
been stirred to action by the zen
education
project curriculum and howard zins of
people's history of the united states
saying quoting me again people reading
it cry and get angry
sometimes taking to the street the zen
book was the most popular book for
occupy wall street protesters
and of quoting me they continue
we at the zen education project plead
guilty
teaching people's history can elicit
great emotion
about oppression and injustice and may
inspire people to move to action
so there you have it teaching people's
history
can elicit great emotion about
oppression
and injustice and may inspire people to
move
to action in their words
these people however are often mere
children
or adolescents so
the zen education project admits to
being an activist
organization they do not even deign to
defend
criticism of their lessons there is more
than enough reason
in my opinion to remove zinn's materials
from
classrooms i think all would agree here
there is no reason
also not yank zen education projects
non-profit status
and educators openly brag about using
zinn's history
we may keep our own children from zinn's
baleful influence but his
today his true believers are out on the
streets
ready to accost anyone refusing to
repeat their revolutionary slogans
and sadly i have heard from many parents
who had homeschooled or privately
schooled their own children
only to have them lured by a professor
or
friend to zinn's seductive
prose not all
students are like hannah wright
who wrote to me last winter about her
zen
worshiping professor who repeated zinn's
own claim to have written history from a
quote different perspective
the professor told her that callings in
biased was offensive
because it meant quote that either the
author
ignored evidence that would have changed
his conclusions
or he didn't bother with evidence at all
end of quote those who would criticize
zinn's book are quote the people who
have a problem with any history book
that does not seek to stimulate a
nationalist
pride in america or are some
joe schmoe on the internet i guess like
me
and she also accused those like me this
professor
that they never provide evidence for
their criticism my book has been out
for over a year now but zinn's book
does not simply present offer another
perspective without question
the falsifications that pepper
every page are intentional it is
propaganda communist disinformation
and as if such a domestic
disinformation campaign were not bad
enough zinn's book is used in
international anti-american
campaigns it has been translated into
more than a dozen languages including
french
spanish chinese and arabic
it has been distributed all over the
world
including in russia by americans
by the bureau of educational and
cultural affairs of the american
embassy which sponsored the
2006 russian language publication
of a people's history of the united
states
a few days ago
to bring us up to date i received an
email
from a journalist in iran
a former american studies student as he
described himself
at the faculty of world studies at the
university of tehran
where he said a people's history was
quote a bible
as it was for anti-americans in iran
it is the only book on u.s
history not published by the regime
in publication in iran
he wrote that he was happy to see my
speech and the white house's initiative
i guess he
caught it on the youtube channel that
the white house has
and he would try to get my book
this young iranian is inspiring
but i i think that we can do more
than someone living in iran in terms of
taking zinn's falsified
communist propaganda out of our schools
and i hope people will
start to work on that so thank you very
[Applause]
much
some time for q a if you have a question
please make your way to one of the
microphones in the side aisles
question on the speaker's right
thank you my name is tanya store and i
am
so grateful to get to be here and and
listen to you today and just
more of a statement i guess um than a
than a question but
this is much deeper than even i was
aware and in january i took a
serious look and actually one of the
reasons that i filed to run
for the nebraska legislature was because
the sitting senator
had co-sponsored a bill to replace
columbus day
with indigenous people day it
struck me as very wrong and as i
continued to do
a little homework and including what
you've shared today
i understand why and and how and i'm
shocked at even how deep
the roots of this go my children were
all raised in a conservative home
went to country school in nebraska
and i i was shocked in a conversation
with my son
who is a conservative a strong christian
young man
about this issue of columbus day and he
agreed we shouldn't be getting rid of
american holidays
absolutely mom i support you in that but
he said something very troubling to me
that woke me up and he said
but you have to admit he wasn't a very
nice guy
and my response to him was who told you
that
and and the conversation you know i it
became aware that somewhere along the
line
um he had been taught in school that he
wasn't a very nice guy and
and i said i was never taught that um i
was taught he was courageous
and he opened up the free world um to
the gospel among many other things
and and his response was well you you do
have to admit your history books were
probably a little whitewashed
um so so this is a young man who was
raised
in a conservative home into a country
school
um in a small rural conservative
community and so
the the the threads of this are much
deeper than i was even aware so thank
you
so much for what what you've done to
bring light to this
thank you
[Applause]
yeah i'm proud to say that i will be
honored by the sons and daughters
of italy in february or
exposing i've got a lot of italian
groups writing to me and thanking me
because what i do in my book is
what zinn did was criminal he
did what every english teacher says you
should not do which is when you use
ellipses those four dots
or three dots that indicate an emission
of words but you're not supposed to
change
you know the meaning right they're not
essential well
he uses ellipses to eliminate two days
worth of
columbus's journal entries and
he misidentifies uh you know
the who they are and that begins the
quotation
and he leaves out words that columbus
wrote down
like uh and i instructed my men to treat
them with kindness for we can convert
them
more by love than by force and has
repeated
uh you know orders to his men
to treat them with kindness he um
even you know had six of them baptized
he adopted
one of them he did everything that
he could to you know convert
the natives he never pillaged or
raped or chopped off hands which is what
you get from zinn's book and it has just
permeated our
understanding or americans understanding
of christopher columbus
and so i'm hoping that you know
when a young man uh like
the questioner's son asks you know and
says that this is you know
he was not a nice guy that at least
i i provide the evidence
i look at the passage
and i look at what zinn says and i say
this is what he's leaving out
and people can go back and they can look
at my
endnotes and there are almost a thousand
of them and
look at the original source and look at
what zin says
and also there you know i have pages of
comparative quotations from zinn
and the guy he quoted from
hans koning and that's not a history
book it's a polemic
so i'm hoping with the evidence you know
that that
um you know zinn was not simply writing
history from another perspective he is
not
simply biased he changes the facts
and we would never use a textbook
that changes the facts or uses a
holocaust denying
historian um as a source
for a textbook this you know zinn's book
was never vetted
and um but yet you know it's been there
for 40 years and it's
trickled down we we have a question on
the speaker's left
mary a couple things number one is i'm
wondering
in your research if you've come across
any evidence of
george soros dirty money funding any of
this zen
project that's my first question and
number two
i would hope that everyone here contacts
their
congressman and emails and writes
letters to them to request this
organization's 501 c
3 status be eliminated
yeah i think there needs to be a public
campaign to pull
um the non-profit status i know from
what i went through just to try to get
my organization going and i was
criticizing common core standards
you know have after having taught
college english
saying that they you know were bad and
um
you know i had to you know they put you
through hell
um i have not come across
you know where the funding comes from
that's not very apparent because the zen
education project
coordinates with rethinking schools and
another
organization that writes the curriculum
and then the zen education project puts
it out there so
it it's not they they don't put their
990s online like a lot of nonprofits do
so that would be an interesting uh thing
to look at
they claim they get a lot of private
donations but i'm
sure um you know that
i wouldn't be surprised um you know
uh the student of howard zinn's from the
1970s bill holtzman
uh you know continues to give money uh
matt damon who wrote
and uh co-starred goodwill hunting gives
money
promotes it so you know you've got some
rich people there
supporting this organization we have a
question on the speakers right
thank you so much i learned so much
today
i'm my question is this is just an
overwhelming
amount of information when you try to
share it with somebody so
we're in an era of sound bites of and so
my question to you is
what are the top three takeaways of what
howard zinn is doing
the effective howard's inn today for our
students
he's he inspires them to hate their own
country
he inspires them to violence
and i think he inspires a sense of
hopelessness
you know in a country because the way he
presents it is that this
country cannot be redeemed as it is
set up through our own government and
when
president trump described
this kind of education as child abuse
it is it really is it's um
you know it sets people up against each
other and
um you know to to tell young people
that you know the country that they live
in is irredeemably
racist and uh unfair
and unjust it you know has got to do
a number on young people
and that and i think you know i would
like to do a survey
of people out there protesting and black
lives matter and antifa
and see how many of them were inspired
by zen
that'd be very interesting we have a
question on the speaker's left
so zinn seemed to make a very long
career on an indictment
of the united states including
especially the founding of it
so if he took his principles and applied
them outward
towards other countries and nations of
the world
what country or nation's history would
pass
muster under zinn's principles
to him i think you probably would say
none but what would he say to that
well what howard zinn does and he uh
takes this from angles and
william z fosters he presents
uh the native tribes living here before
the europeans came
as this kind of bucolic paradise
where there was no war where women were
empowered
where people were free there was no
greed
which is the exact opposite of the way
it was
and so these were kind of proto-hippies
the way he presents them you know
remember he is
someone of the 1960s that was the heyday
for him
and so he claims like other communist
propagandists do that the native people
lived in this paradise where they shared
and he implies that if we sort of
drop all the characteristics of
eurocentrism or
western civilization like hierarchies
and linear thought and you know all
those uh
you know criticisms of you know that
post-modernists have that we can return
to that sort of garden of eden that
that's
that's who it is and he also he also
claims that in other countries like
vietnam that the communist movements
were
local movements the people just rising
up
and trying to you know have more
control over their own government and
live more fairly and justly
we have a question on the speaker's
right
i've been listening to the nonsense of
the
liberals for many many years
and i fail to understand why seemingly
intelligent people can let themselves be
seduced by
this these thoughts is it they they have
envy the freedom that we have or do they
just want to control
everybody and everything that they do
well zen targets and people who use this
materials
target young people and
what zinn hides in his book
you know are the horrors of communism
so if you get only one side of history
and you don't know any other and
increasingly as surveys
show young people are ignorant about
history
and um and there is a false reality
that's created
and i think this is part of uh
you know the propaganda that's taught in
our
schools so a student can say
well you know um you know we have
affirmative
action uh our
laws are race new supposed to be race
neutral
um i see kids of all races and
ethnicities of varying
income levels but if they
have this material pounded into them day
after day
they begin to believe it and also one of
the
things that i critiqued about common
core is the teaching
strategies have changed we now have
social and emotional learning
so students aren't sitting down
and reading long works discussing them
in class
listening to lectures they get short
snippets you know selected for their
emotional appeal
and they're told to uh you know just
discuss
in their groups they're graded on their
ability to respect you know diversity
and one of the things about howard zinn
and i you know i focused
mostly on the facts that he twists
around
the deliberate disinformation along with
a chapter
on his sordid life which is kind of
interesting
notorious womanizer with his students
is is his very skillful
use of propaganda
to someone who is young and naive and
doesn't know any better
they get sucked up into it they
you people even adults say that
they cry after they read howard zinn's
book
they get angry
so you know he he was kind of an evil
genius
he knew what he was doing and he
used the techniques of propaganda david
horowitz
called it the mind conf of american
history
and he uses the same strategies
and i you know and i think students also
need to be
taught you know what our legitimate
history
writing techniques how is
someone manipulating your emotions
with words so
you know we we need to start teaching
that again
and this reliance on emotion i think
is is you know swaying people and it
sort of clouds their judgment
all right please join me in thanking dr
[Applause]
graybar